moi je suis en respect absolu du droit
constitutionnel à manifester à faire
grève parfois je continue en revanche et
je continuerai à le faire à dénoncer ce
qui appelle au blocage partout tout le
temps et qui appelle pour reprendre
certains mots à mettre l'économie
française à genoux je pense que quand on
appelle à mettre l'économie française à
genoux on appelle à mettre des
entreprises à genoux des usines à genoux
des travailleurs français à genoux et ça
je ne crois pas qu'une majorité de
Français le souhaite il y a des
manifestations encore une fois elles
sont légitimes il y a un nombre
important de Français qui défile contre
cette réforme ce que je souhaite c'est
que dans cette hémicycle continue à se
manifester l'expression du débat
démocratique et de nos institutions
c'est ce que j'ai perçu depuis le début
de l'examen de ce texte et puisque vous
avez convoqué
fait référence aux manifestations à
l'occasion de vos interventions et c'est
parfaitement légitime c'est une partie
de ce qui se joue dans le pays vous me
permettrez aussi de faire référence à
ces dizaines de millions de Français qui
ce matin ce sont levés encore plus tôt
que d'habitude pour pouvoir aller
travailler assez centaine de milliers
d'artisans de commerçants qui se sont
levés pour faire tourner leur entreprise
dans un contexte difficile à ces
dizaines de millions de Français qui
parfois sont opposés à la réforme mais
qui n'ont d'autre choix que d'aller
travailler parfois des agents publics
même des soignants des enseignants des
policiers des douaniers qui sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui vous me permettrez
puisque vous ne l'avez pas fait de faire
référence à ces dizaines de millions de
Français qui font tourner notre pays
aujourd'hui comme tous les autres jours
malgré les grèves malgré les
manifestations malgré les blocages je
pense qu'ils sont aussi légitimes à ce
qu'on parle d'eux à ce qu'on fasse
référence à eux à ce qu'on les ait aussi
à l'esprit
[Musique]